[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci dr marie
et
m
[Musique]
merci
bonjour je suis devant l'entrée
principale du drs où nous avons rendez
vous avec une chercheuse passionnante
bonjour je suis sylvette le paient
bonjour madame
allons-y
n'oubliez pas vous prenez michy tout ça
c'est très aimable à vous d'avoir
accepté de me recevoir mais c'est normal
asseyez vous je vous en prie en tant que
scientifique nous devons tout faire afin
que ne se creuse davantage le fossé qui
nous sépare du reste de la population
entre et excusez moi madame le paient
donc j'arrive pas les voyons ça tu la
vois ma grosse pas effectivement ces
bêtes hobbit mais on est très mal
attendez attendez ya le contexte gbit ma
petite sans aucun doute bits
merci madame excusez moi oui le serez
vous je crois qu'ils avaient créé ce
département du drs oui non le
département de sémantique général
existait déjà depuis de nombreuses
années lorsque j'en ai pris la direction
oui mais à cette époque là très peu de
femmes assurées de telles
responsabilités
n'exagérez pas marie curie avait déjà
découvert le radium vous savez excusez
moi à l'eau ainsi vous cher m ar oui
tout à fait tout à fait c'est même très
intéressant attendez je note
oui voilà allez-y on veut vieille [ __ ]
on aurait dû vous mettre faire au co car
vous l'aviez brûlants comme breizh a
tout à fait tout à fait surtout dans un
texte du xiiie où la plupart du temps on
utilise chaque plutôt que qu'on est bien
je communique tout ça forestier au
revoir m je vous en prie exclusive va
tous vous avez été une des prendre
oui oui brunelli pour la 20e fois
brunelli nous avons tous décidé
d'inclure dans la mémoire pipi et caca
seul gros pow pow reste en suspens eh
bien vous vous débrouillerez avec le
professeur quand alain c'est tout
brunelli venez je vais vous faire
visiter le service 5 ou l'ado un coup la
daf higuain blood pas fini or à
l'habitat la ville malgré ce crabe est
potes et on veut ici la partie de notre
institut est ouverte aux chercheurs du
monde entier
mariko a dit wang
et vous savez que l'on prononce votre
nom pour le prochain noël
je vais vous surprendre mais je
n'accepterai avec plissement bonjour
bonjour nantis se mêle alors vous en
sortez avec votre du cul oui ça va ça va
plus clémente y voyons ça nous
approchons mon petit samuel nous
approchons bras beaucoup et si vous
deviez résumer vos principaux problèmes
vous savez les problèmes sont tous ceux
de la recherche française des problèmes
de primes aillent bien ou ministre des
promesses toujours des promesses
malheureusement très mission aidera à
mieux faire entendre votre voix
je le souhaite et je vous en remercie
je viens je ne vous raconte pas mon
objectif je connais le chemin et merci
encore
zut
oh non c'est pas vrai qu'on en attendait
c'est fou comment tout va et ça fait
combien de temps je sais pas moi ça fait
mais dis-moi était toujours en plastique
oui enfin dans le vinyle maintenant
quand en groupe c'est le même ton mais
j'ai 100 mg france
ça me fait plaisir ça l'histoire
ben moi toujours des gens pareils que
souvent les assurances c'est vrai était
un pilier la laborieuse lorraine newey
enfin appelé seppuku lui disons que
j'emploie star mondiale pour portables
va dire que je devrais en plus comme ça
aussi
quand je pense que c est connu c'est
fait vidéo didot faut absolument que tu
es de manger à la maison accessoires
avec plaisir à ça avec plaisir avec
plaisir un plaisir à carmen carmen quel
temps favori je me sauve mais on sent
pas là bas je t'appelle mon intolérance
d'accord remis en état tampon disant ok
allez voir mais qu'est-ce qui tombe
aujourd'hui on parle pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez tous la patrouille de
france cette magnifique escadrille
capable des plus folles acrobaties à des
vitesses supersoniques
ces hommes qui le 14 juillet pour la
joie des grands et des petits
un prime dans le ciel notre beau drapeau
français
mais savez vous comment on devient l'un
de ces as de l'aviation qui font partie
des meilleurs pilotes du monde en tenue
que tous nos gars au départ sont triés
sur le volet c'est relativement deux ans
il faut compter deux ans pour qu'une
jeune recrue soit membre de la
patrouille de france oui s'il ne craque
pas bien sûr vous avez beaucoup
d'abandons son côté la % environ
l'entraînement est très dur disons qu'il
est soutenu et rigoureux c'est un
entraînement que j'ai mis au point avec
le général d'at rôle il ya sept ans et
qui donne de très bons résultats et en
quoi consiste-t-il mon colonel nos gars
s'entraînent sans avion
pour de contrôle tour de contrôle à
charlie bravo roger piqué du nez et
comment ces formations vraie question
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est charlie bravo roger prennent pas
puisque c'est votre droit
ok mais avez vous atterri en formation
déployés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
papapapa
faudra faire des pompes alex s'émousse
un jour tu dois finir par avoir un état
au décollage
[Musique]
et
le
[Musique]
c'est l'arrière
coupe les gaz
un plombage qui livre je crois que tu
voles avec sa maman collin attentiste
c'est tout bien le bonjour les gars je
peux vous poser une question
on s'habitue vite à ce genre de vie rue
tue au départ c'est un petit peu
impressionnant quand même pour avouer la
première fois qu'on y va en cours dans
le pré convoi l'herbe défilent à toute
allure sous les pieds ça date un peu
habitant du contenu des lots moi non
mais c'est ça oui au début ce qui est
plus impressionnant surtout c'est le
rase mottes l'appétit
j'avais contribué
au bout de deux ans on fin de stage
quand nos petits gars sont bien prêts
nous les préparons pour le 14 juillet
c'est l'exercice auquel vous avez
assisté
je vous en prie merci
asseyez
[Musique]
très impressionnant
anoh alpha tango et 6 tours de contrôle
alpha tango quelque chose qui cloche
répondez et cc infos bordeaux je crois
que j'ai un caillou dans la chaussure
je vais se donner au maximum des
crochets alpha tango inutile d'insister
alpha tango
quitte à ce crétin d'atterrir
immédiatement mais mon colonel alpha
tango atterrissez c'est un ordre ce qui
l'attend ce fou
fargo répondait afin tango répondait
répondent-elles fargo 6 tours de
contrôle répondait ça tango à sa tango
au col d'eze basé sur le coupé alfa tct
encore répondu
[Musique]
je pense t-il
je vais vous demander d'être poussés
[Musique]
c'est ça aussi la patrouille de france
professeur stenson nous précise je cite
la trempe des éléphants d'hannibal ne
tirait pas des obus de 75 comme on le
croit généralement
elle servait de longues vues au
conducteur assis à l'intérieur de
l'éléphant les courses à vincennes
oublie palpable 8 mars 82 le physicien
henry thibault alors qu'il travaille sur
la chute des corps établi la fameuse loi
selon laquelle quel que soit l'homme que
l'on pousse d'une muraille de plus de 10
mètres s'il tient une tartine à la main
elle touche toujours le sol du côté
beurré besançon après cinq années de
démarches administratives un employé des
postes de besançon monsieur jean-pierre
fait nous y voir ta c est qu on se marre
un coup a obtenu de changer de nom il
s'appelle désormais monsieur jean-pierre
aussi
un inconnu s'est jeté hier matin dans la
fosse aux lions du zoo de vincennes en
criant je cite je suis le roi des
animaux ils devaient indiqué peu après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
régime ce matin ça fait chier un quai
l'on connaît mardi c'est mardi gym ça
fait chier
et toi c'est qu'un jour tu as gym toi
hein c'était le jour j
ouais mais c'est vendredi magie main
lors quoi
[Musique]
gymglish
mais hier c'est encore moi qu'à la boue
gêne pour la peau qu'elle reconnaît
mardi gym ça me fait chier oh merde
c'est l'échangé même pas quand ces
joueurs parce que comme chez cora et la
confiance et l on doit s'accrocher mais
non massés vendredi à la merde c'est
rambouillet s'est brûlé j'aime pas quand
c'est brûler je pense qu hier
[Applaudissements]
hector r vendredi dernier à la gym et
ben tu vois ginette lemercier ses
poulets le pied du don oh merde c'est
encore de la confiture d'abricots j'aime
pas la confiture d'abricots on s'est
parlé jouent combien mardi si on nous
attaque
la dernière fois il avait cru qu'ils
viendraient l'aldi total et sont passés
mercredi alors que votre majesté me
pardonne mon intrusion intempestive
l'heure est grave si le château est
cerné
c'est la révolution le peuple est
marches du palais j'aime pas le peuple
[Applaudissements]
fort de 90 ans
roi du gameplay je peux pas l'attraper
en mangeant
évidemment tu es parfaitement
je m'appelle rené il y a deux femmes en
moi l'une sage bien élevé aimons la vie
de famille et les jeux de société
par exemple je suis très forte au
scrabble l'autre perverse vicieuse
briseuse de ménage
bref ne [ __ ] je cherche deux hommes
qui pourraient me comprendre et me
rendre heureuse évidemment des jumeaux
serait l'idéal
monsieur ne croit pas au père noël j'ai
45 ans je dirige deux multinationales
ainsi qu'une petite scierie en province
qui je le pense a toutes les chances de
devenir grandes
je partage mon temps entre la suisse
deux mois l'hiver et bisons salle et mon
bateau qui m'amène tous les étés avec
une vingtaine d'amis vers les îles
grecques
j'ai un hobby la voiture j'en ai 9
voilà maintenant j'aimerais rencontrer
une femme qui même pour moi même et
d'ailleurs je suis prêt à payer pour
cela
c'est une transe alité sont raisonnables
bien entendu
[Musique]
un caroline avait six ans et moi
peut-être nov
c'est curieux rappelle comme si c'était
hier
elle tenait entre ses petits doigts
d'enfants une cigarette en chocolat et
s'apprêtait à la porter à sa bouche
lorsque tout à coup
après avoir croisé mon regard a changé
d'avis et 20 brusquement m'écraser la
cigarette ou le visent et là toute ma
vie a basculé
puis après ça va commencer les
cigarettes à l'eucalyptus d'abord elle
me laisse écrasait tout et puis les
premières américaines
les anglaises les françaises il me les
écraser les boues fifres les maïs
laissant filtrer les écraser tous les
cigarillos les arabes
les [ __ ] elle m'a écrasé toute là les
cigarillos les avale tout sur les
carrosseries envier bon nous allons en
rester là pour aujourd'hui monsieur
macquart
mais rien n'est ce pas docteur nous
sommes sur la bonne voie
encore quelques séances
je vais m'en sortir un docteur mais vous
souffrez d'un complexe banal monsieur
mac dans notre jargon de métier l'aplomb
le complexe du cendrier c'est très bien
fait beaucoup de bien ce que vous me
dites a doctor beaucoup je vous dois
mais comme d'habitude 800 francs contre
encore non team docteur faye âge où je
sens que je me reprends caroline dans le
petit village du perray dordogne on
vient de découvrir une cabine
téléphonique ou le dimanche on peut
obtenir dieu entre 5 et 6 bien entendu
oui oui oui les choses et quoi ton oui
je vous le passez à bientôt
[Applaudissements]
en général on le dimanche entre 17 et 18
heures mais c'est arrivé comment la
première fois à bâle à prendre la face
et lui il était énervé et au lieu de
mettre une pièce de monnaie dans la
fente il a mis une ch'ti et puis là on
l'a eu en face de la lune avant et vous
vous lui avez parlé longtemps pour trois
minutes un an minutes et après il ya la
petite lumière qui s'est remise à
clignoter
alors on a remis une hostie et puis on
c'était reparti pour trois minutes à
vous pouvez le joindre tous les jours
non malheureusement sur le mans le
dimanche on voit les mêmes d'ailleurs là
je crois que il faut y aller voir ma
fille tu as tes austin oui bien sûr
d'avoir ma fille avant mes pairs à vous
les studios
[Musique]